I've been on this kick forever and it  really does [ __ ] matter  um the amount of people I just DM  who I don't even know and just say keep  going love what you're doing  give encouragement the amount of friends  and acquaintances I just check in on  randomly just text and say love you hope  you're well what's cooking you never  know when you perfectly time your text  when somebody needs you so so so bad  when they just want you when the sirens  are going off in their life  thank you God when the sirens are going  off in their life and you can be the  person that actually triggers A New  Perspective or uh extra boost or it  might not even be that serious it's just  giving somebody a smile  um that needed one that day that was not  that they were having a bad day they're  just having a normal day and a smile  just made it better friends  acquaintances former classmates former  teammates former co-workers  people you admire on social DM and text  say what's up say what's up